bonjour essais cliniques nos qui vous
parlent se trouve que j'ai été contacté
par la prof afin de reprendre mon rôle
de lucrecia pour la saison 2 de taymor
évidemment depuis la saison j'ai connu
un immense succès dans le milieu
cinématographique et j'ai obtenu moult
récompenses pour mes talents d'actrice
il est donc assez évident qu étant donné
que ma renommée a explosé je ne peux pas
me contenter des conditions de travail
de la dernière fois je n'ai donc accepté
de jouer dans cette saison 2 de
notamment qu'à condition que les
conditions mais spa soient remplies j'ai
donc fourni à la prof une liste de mes
nouvelles exigences quant à les
conditions de travail pour cette saison
deux exigences évidemment en lien avec
ma renommée toute nouvelle
il est bien sûr évident que je refuse de
partager la loge avec ses autres
comédiens je souhaite également avoir
une masseuse personnel pour me détendre
entre chaque prise
une augmentation de salaire cela va de
soi un chauffeur pour pouvoir mener sur
les différents lieux de tournage sans
que j'aie à conduire moi même et je
souhaite également avoir un assistant
personnel qui pourrait à tout moment de
la journée à tout art à chaque seconde
subvenir à mes besoins essentiels et je
souhaite que cet éclat assistant
répondent au doux nom de tom hiddleston
et quand je dis tom hiddleston je parle
bien entendu de l'acteur qui joue l'eau
qui je ne parle pas d'une personne qui
aurait le même nom et le même prix non
tout ça pour vous dire que la prof a mis
en place un projet hull
afin de financer notre saison 2 de the
time world et de me financer mois en
fait finalement non tous les cas oscars
et moi nous vous remercions par avance
de votre grande générosité à notre égard
à bientôt les amours